she was always so gracious aye and
welcoming presidential hopeful Hillary
Clinton attended Nancy Reagan's funeral
Friday et spoke with her just before she
walked in Clinton knew the Reagan's well
and remembered Nancy and Ronald's love
story they just were madly in love I
think from the very beginning until I'm
sure the very last minute
it was so obvious when you were around
both of them behind the scenes she
played a very important role in a lot of
the most difficult issues you know
whether or not President Reagan should
deal with the new president of the
Soviet Union Gorbachev she encouraged
that he did and I think history is the
better for it
I also remember her strength and her
resolve
following the attempted assassination of
her husband something that was so
shocking and terrible and you know she
really helped to guide our country
through that time so today we honor a
woman who really just provided so much
to our country not only in her support
and love for her husband but in her work
on Alzheimer's and so much else the war
against drugs and her just say no
campaign she made a very historic
important set of contributions to our
country